Hey Merlin
Yea?
Do you really think this could have fallen of an airliner?
Oh Yeah, Sure.
It's Halogen. Too bad it didn't hit ya, Could of sued.
Hey, You coming for a drink?
No, I can't Tonight.
Alright
See you tomorrow
Hello
How do
How's it going truman?
*sighs* not bad
I just won the state lottery
Good, good.
Tyronne
What would you do if i said i didnt want meatball today?
Id ask for identification *chuckles*
See ya tomorrw Truman.
Probably
Thanks
*suspicious music*
*suspicious music intensifies*
*stares intently*
Everybody just stay focused
remember who you are
Woman: I love Paris
Man: Its Pretty Cool
Both: Yeah
Vamos señorita
Beunos!
*chatting indistinctly*
Hey!
It's You isn't it??
Excuse me?
Remember me??
2 days ago I gave you my meatball sandwich in the park!
you were in a wheelchair
you said "ggrrunghughyea"
same shoes
Jogging partner: You got the wrong guy buddy
its a miracle!!